my name is shannon taro Okamoto i'm an
ice sculptor today I've been challenged
to create an ice sculpture in ten levels
of increase in complexity
[Applause]
so today we're making three sculptures
first with hand tools only then with
power tools
and then lastly with use of computers
and CNC angelfish has been a kind of
historical design within the ice
sculpture community and it's something
that I think is familiar of shape enough
and interesting shape enough to really
kind of expand into so the concept of
sculpt in itself will remain constant
removing the excess material around the
design refining the dimensional shape
and then finishing with details
this can be approached in many different
ways for this project I just simply
wanted to break it in terms of the
lineage of technology now this is a
fishbone mold and this is not what we'll
be making today first we got to talk
about the material the ice now we make
our own ice each machine makes two
blocks each block about 37 gallons takes
about three days about 275 pounds and it
creates a crystal clear of dense the
frozen block of ice crystal clear blocks
are made with two important processes
one is one direction freezing that
freezes from bottom up by freezing ice
one direction he allows air bubbles to
lift up to the surface and also
circulation of water as it freezes so by
agitating the water releases any kind of
still air bubbles or impurities that may
remain on the on the surface as it
freezes first sculpture with just hand
tools it's the most traditional approach
to ice carving for us we'll start with
the block of ice have a design at hand
study the design and then we will
literally kind of draw the design onto
the ice surface usually with an ice pick
or a little handsaw
so once the design is established onto
the surface of the block then the first
tool at hand will be the big handsome
it's an awesome tool it's beautiful and
it's a to work with so hand saw is
a beast a saw but the design it has to
be pretty basic free you know simple
straight lines you can't really carve
away in any kind of curvature this is
really meant to take away big chunks of
ice in series of straight lines so once
the big saw is used to take away any
just excess ice the next level would be
to pick up the big flat chisels to take
away more ice but in a slightly more
nuanced manner bigger the chisel more
surface it can take away so as we're
trying to still define the outer contour
of the shape bigger chisel or health
motives to work with the flat chisel you
first have to have a basic knowledge of
chisel and our chisel has a beveled
front and a flat back and you know the
use of two sides will give us two
different effects creating a form that's
concave or convex and by having those
two together we can kind of follow any
kind of contour so we try to achieve so
after the the big tools are gone the
next level would be to pick up the
smaller tools like small pistol saws two
hand saws to smaller chisels it allows
us to refine the overall shape more and
then go into detailing like carbonize or
scales as we enter the refining detail
in stage we just have to be aware of
just being more delicate with our
pressure onto the surfaces of the ice I
think everything is getting thinner and
more refined
so the tools just naturally
smaller so once the overall shape of the
angelfish is ready then I would pick up
the V chisel to finish the detailing so
the V chisels
he eats on to the surface of the ice and
you can really scribe onto the surface
and give a deep line onto the surface
that can really add refraction when
looked at and last longer onto the
surface of the ice with smaller chisels
we can hone down into parts of the
design like for this angel fish lifting
the pectoral fins perhaps or the Bulge
around the eyes he allows us to more
easily access that area without damaging
other areas we often have to adjust the
design we're carving based on the
limitation of the tools we use so for
you know a hand tools only approach the
design would have to be stylized and
then simplified to make the best of what
we got once the sculpture is finished
with all the you know carving details
the rest is just cleaning up for
presentation I've done that since I was
fifteen second sculpture with parties in
the most basic level sculpting you're
given a material and work within the
material to step up that level then we
want to think outside the frame so we
can bring in more materials and then
fusing blocks onto the surface to make
sculpture bigger than the actual block
that we were first given by having the
opportunity to add ice allows us to
compose a more dynamic design and allows
us to play with more details
so fusing block entails the use of the
aluminum plate a heating plate to clean
up all the surfaces that - ice will come
together so it's a perfect match and
minimum one of the two ice has to be
very cold to bite onto the ice surface
you know ice behaves very differently in
nuanced gradations of temperature when
it's really really cold fusing of blocks
of ice with with squirt of water alone
doesn't work so you have to create
channels for the waters to go into to
spread and then when it's really really
warm then you have to think about the
use of you know dry ice and it's it's a
it's a tricky tricky thing so now that
we have the block form ready for cutting
we will pick up an electric chainsaw to
cut the overall shape
[Applause]
so while the big saw is limited to
straight lines electric chainsaws allows
us to really work various contours of
various shapes and being a very powerful
tool it really allows us to more
efficiently tackle bigger ice without
taxing ourselves too much so the use of
chainsaw really gives us a step-up in
efficiency just one chainsaw can pretty
much take over everything that a big saw
and a big tool would have done in a hand
to little stage chainsaw itself is
slightly modified to cut ice of a chain
that come off the shelf is designed to
cut wood got a kickback teeth on it that
prevents us from cutting ice as well as
we were like after the chainsaw work is
done the overall shape is pretty much
there I would say no matter how big or
small to design we would probably do
about 60 70 percent of the sculpture of
a chainsaw only so now that the chainsaw
part is done then we will really jump
into level of detailing the weekend we
can play with and that's done with die
grinders and specialized bits in
comparison to you know hand tool only
stage the use of Zhai grinders really
allows us to give very refined minut
detailing of the shapes and effects do
we want to give to the surfaces it's a
very smooth volume that we can create
and even the nuanced curvature of the
overall shape can be really achieved by
playing with these shaper bits
[Music]
and then from there I'll probably pick
up the needle bits to really start
drawing the the scales and even this you
know compared to V chisels that's again
still more of a series of straight lines
we can really start giving curves of
scales or play with different angles of
the bits going into the ice surface so
that it looks like it's it's layering of
scales not just sitting next to each
other profession seas of the needle bits
can really deepen the explorations of
the details you can give and you know
I'll probably do some finishing touches
with bubble bits maybe use that to
create a nice you know kind of a bowl be
eyeballs of the fish I can give a nice
little finish next we're going to really
explore the most complex design possible
thanks to the use of computers and CNC
robots the CNC robot consists for this
sculpture a flatbed with spindle that's
attached to a CNC contraption which has
X Y and z-axis that will correspond to
different data that comes from the
drawing that's done on the computer the
carving process will be done inside the
freezer now because CNC machine exists
inside the freezer everything that works
with the machine has to be very stable
and ice must remain stable and thus the
freezer work and for each level I've
designated different size of bits that
can range from a half inch bit for the
outer shape all the way down to one
sixteenth of the bit
you know by having the numbers that the
precision to our arsenal
he allows us to create a form that's
really daring and give kind of details
that's just not possible by hand
I want to design a skeletal structure
and then piece it together with several
blocks of ice so that we can give more
dynamic overall design to the shape more
backgrounds more foregrounds maybe
really expand the narrative the overall
compositions maybe dimensional bubbles
that could be coming out from the
sculpture maybe give a little a coral
structure in the front really just you
know deepen the complexity of the
overall sculpture we can go further into
technology there are 3d carving machines
out there there are arms that you know
create various automated structures now
that can finish sculpture completely
without touching at all but that's a
whole nother realm of programming for us
the use of CNC robot is as far as we
take it
people often ask it's you know sad for
us to see the sculpture civvy creates
that would spend you know amounts of
time and material to do simply to kind
of melt away but for us I think as a
practicing artist working with ice is
quite liberating so it allows us to
focus on the process itself and also we
see ice sculpture as more performative
the finishing peak is really when leaves
our studio and it's out and and melting
thank you wired
[Music]